bonjour météo ghisalberti merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
la courbe s'inverse en italie les
mesures de confinement commence enfin à
porter leurs fruits
oui effectivement on a l'impression que
heureusement il ya des bonnes nouvelles
qui arrivent depuis le terrain depuis
les hôpitaux italiens
il y a effectivement une baisse des
monts dire des personnes qui vend aux
urgences et surtout à celles qui sont
hospitalisés en thérapie intensive mais
ils les autorités invitent toujours à
être prudent parce que une sortie trop
rapide du confinement pour evans eefje
tous les efforts faits jusqu'à ce moment
je suis à quoi pourrait durer justement
ce confinement du côté de l'italie selon
vous
c'est difficile à dire mais le
responsable de la protection civile à
avancer une date
qui est celle du 13 mai mais c'est tout
dépend effectivement de l'évolution dans
ces prochains jours ce qui est certain
c'est que dans certains régions
notamment la lombardie désormais c'est
obligatoire le port du masque ou des
quelque forme de protection du visage
disons que plutôt que laisser les gens à
l'air libre disons avec zéro protection
c'est mieux qu'il se promène tout en
respectant les distances de sécurité des
sites associations sociales les mesures
distanciation social avec au moins des
écharpes etc
on a une expression italienne qui est
celle de plutôt que rien samu est plutôt
et donc pour bien sûr on s'est calé les
écharpes ou des foulards ne sont pas des
protections total mais évite en tout cas
de la course du virus si les chiffres se
confirment à rome envisage un plan de
redémarrage de l'économie avec une
reprise d'activité progressive à la
mi-mai vous avez donc parler du 13-mai
réalisable selon vous où vous prennent
un curé je pense que sans doute il
faudra
pouvoir avoir des ressources sur souffre
surtout économique pour permettre déjà
le paiement des salaires de personnes
qui ont été laissés un un chômage
technique ou total faut aussi rappeler
aussi capital il n'ya pas l'état social
qui existe en france donc il y a pas
toute une série de mesures des mesures
de protection des revenus des foyers
et puis naturellement il faudra
rapatrier
comme c'est un peu le cas de la france
des activités des productions
stratégiques notamment celle des masques
mais aussi intensifier le retour de
production par exemple de médicaments
pour éviter que l'italie fait face à
trouver un an préparer au cadre d'une
flambée une nouvelle du virus sans se
rappeler aussi que le virus pour la pour
le moment heureusement n'a pas touché
gravement le sud de l'italie mais en
craignent qu'avec les beaux jours et
donc la possibilité de bouger
elle a plus facilement la contamination
arrive aussi dans le sud où il y a un
système qui est un peu moins performant
par rapport à celui d'une heure mais de
toute façon dans des standards européens
la présidente de la commission
européenne ours ou la van der leyen
s'est excusé la semaine dernière
vis-à-vis de rome je cite ou beaucoup
trop n'ont pensé qu'à leurs problèmes
nationaux
comment les italiens ont accueilli ce
mea culpa du côté
de bruxelles que les états n'y ont vu
que si d'un côté la parole on me dit
c'est qu'effectivement l'italie ne
pouvait pas être laissés seuls dans les
faits il ya eu une âme une mois et qui
c'est qui qui est née entre le nord et
le sud de l'europe
beaucoup d'italiens que jusqu'à il ya
quelques années étaient des héros fils
convaincu beaucoup d'italiens maintenant
se disait pourquoi on doit rester en
europe si il n'y a pas une solidarité
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'italiens ont aussi
remarqué que les aides par exemple d'
équipes pour nettoyer pour désinfecter
les maisons de retraite les ehpad ou
bien les hôpitaux venez et d'autres pays
que celui de l'union européenne
notamment la russie l'albanie le cuba et
même la chine
donc ça vite fait pour le constat les
italiens se sont abandonnés une fois de
plus après la crise des migrants et donc
je pense que l'heure les relations avec
l'europe seront très difficiles après
c'est le mot de la fin merci matteo
bisel berthier d'avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes et le
rédacteur en chef du site d'informations
putsch médias